facetime video
no baby oh no what what
what's uh what's wrong look at that hair
you've gone for the top not b well it
goes all over my face otherwise don't it
be
well b um as you can see
i've been having to make several videos
without you in them and uh
i'm sick of it to be honest i've got no
one to talk to with these things
oh well i'm sick of not being in them
i've just got them to talk to period
for those who don't know dan and i for
eight of the ten years we've been doing
this channel
um we've lived about five thousand miles
apart two different continents
and currently due to planetary
pandemic situations we can't travel
to each other i technically i can go to
england but i have a real hard time
uh getting back here and then uh we
don't have cameras in england and
you can only come here if you're a
diplomat right
i think it's if you're a diplomat the
queen or you're like american or
something like that
so i've had an idea um we can't make
videos during the pandemic
but there's nothing stopping us from
making a video
before the pandemic
i mean i could think of a couple of
problems with that right
go ahead firstly um
that would require time travel yeah
um yeah so that would be the main
problem you're 100 right
um i was thinking if any youtuber had a
time machine it would probably be colin
first and we've never made a video with
him before he's always doing mad stuff
so i think we'll get if we get hold of
colin and then we'll just
plan a time when we were both free
yeah it's very rare that we were both
together but not filming slo-mo guys so
when would be a good time uh i know you
came back to england for a bit
because you were like just one of the
rest yeah there was a time between
super slow show and planet slo-mo where
i just had a restful week in england we
didn't film anything but we were both
together
yeah just having a laugh if colin was
free that week
perfect i think that might work we could
sort out a phantom rental
nearby place should i give him a should
i give him a bell
yeah give him a call all right hold on
hey all right colin how's it going we're
here right slow-mo's what are we up to
uh wondering what the uh chances are of
you having a time machine
what's the time machine stitch yeah
what's the time machine sit
i've kind of got a time machine well
i've kind of got i've got well maybe
50 50 of it 50
better than now to be honest well yeah i
mean that's at least 50 percent more of
a time machine than we've got
full blown delorean yeah that's pretty
sweet um colin we're wondering about a
cheeky
collab are you free or should i say
were you free in november of 2017.
november 2017. let me think all right
there'd be a gap when i was building the
tie
fighter up at tom's farm you couldn't
see me there i think that'd work
all right brilliant colin um pick us up
when you're ready
stick the kettle on yeah excellent right
i'll get it sorted and i'll presume we
had a lovely time well i'll know in a
minute when i
yeah yeah look uh look forward to it
wait looked forward to it
no i don't know i don't know
yeah i can't wait couldn't wait i
couldn't have waited
what yeah
hello i'm gav i'm dan we're the slow-mo
guys and today
we're not in my back garden in fact you
may realize where we are
already we are in a prop shed though
it's true quite different from ours ours
has you know bits of string balloons
condoms maybe a spade
this one's got wolverine claws magnet
boots real mantles like lathes and
all sorts of cool stuff it also contains
colin furs
oh yes me how's it going thanks for
having us colin
uh this is a very famous room and i'm
delighted to be stood in it
yeah so what we're going to film today
in slo-mo well i've got one of these
oh just casually lying around the poster
engine
now these things are super cool they
make like loads of noise they go
red hot they spit fire out they're
awesome but everyone always asks me
how do they work what's going on inside
so i thought well you know
you two could come in really handy yeah
it seems like we should point one of
these at it phantom flex 4k
right through the window yup get a
thousand frames a second easy sounds
good are we
are we doing it here in the machine
we're not doing it in here
all right okay good good right onwards
i'm bringing my cuppa
oh jealous now we're in the field
right look at this dry stone wall here
yeah lovely little view
ah the pulse jetting right we're good to
rock
there we are here we are then pulse jet
slo-mo guys
got the high-speed camera set up they
don't know what's going to happen yet
he's just going to push the trigger
when he thinks he should do right let's
get it started
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i think that's the right word it is
kind of like the eye of mordor
a little bit yeah
for those of you who don't know what the
pulse jet actually is if you haven't
seen collins videos uh what it's doing
is creating
explosions in this chamber and it sends
a wave of pressure out the long and
short ends of the tube
that's the jet part as the wave expands
it leaves a near vacuum behind in the
chamber so
fresh air and oxygen rush in the short
end and hot gas is
sucked back from the long end which
ignites a new burst of fuel
and the whole cycle repeats itself many
times a second which is why it's very
useful to be filming this with the
phantom
shall we then now we've got that should
we try and rev it a bit harder
so i'll rev it up a little bit push the
red button and then switch it off yeah
colin is now uh operating phantom so we
don't need it
[Music]
fire always looks kind of cg to me when
it's this slow this is 3000 frames a
second
it looks like it's just going in one
direction but if i speed it up slightly
you can see that it's sort of swaying
inside the cylinder
yeah should we start filming down the
spout then yeah
we haven't even got it glowing yet
it's close we get the whole thing
glowing red nearly
so you may have noticed here that the
camera is about
what a foot from danger actually it's
probably 14 inches
yeah um every man overestimates always
quite scary shoving a phantom
down the danger hole but that's where
you get the best footage this is
it's like the best angle all right
uh
coming back down a little bit isn't it
back down the barrel
like that's a point here because it yeah
suck more air in it yeah
if we do rev it even harder you will get
flames
they'll they might travel further so
move back on the camera and rub it off
yeah yeah i think so
14 inches
so we're a little bit further back and
uh colin is going to give it
all the beans this time
[Music]
now i don't know if you saw it but when
that was first getting going yeah there
was a
massive flame like all around here yeah
just something
did you see that i didn't see it it's
like right on your end
mine or is it both of yours
it was just like i guess some excess
loose gas that was just proof oh that's
always good to know
the thing is a bit of loose gas flying
around it's just burning itself it's not
using us as burning material it's
actually just like a nice heater
first
is that smoke or is that flame have a
look at this what is this
what am i looking at that's not right
that's blue flame let me see
yeah you see you can see it breathing
now you can see it boom
oh that's wicked actually
so for this one my job is just stand
still dan is a human background
i have a background uh you're doing the
job of
two c-stands i'm also wearing ear
defenders because i'm gonna go deaf
if it starts going right next to my head
so this is the first shot we're doing
from the outside
just looking at see if we get any flame
coming out the spout see if we can film
this the spitty spitty stuff
am i safe here yeah you're fine see
he says well just you know flames come
out just move
just she'll be all right i love it for a
brief moment you'll be hotter
um
oh it's kicking a bit good good reflexes
right over the top of your head
my hoodie's like burning to a crisp here
feel my hoodie this was soft a minute
feel this
it's gone like crunchy that's all right
stick it down stick
in the washing machine it'll be fine
brilliant you feel the heat dan yeah
yeah see it rippling i can see it
[Music]
yeah with the winds being thrown around
well if that was wet it wouldn't be for
much
[Music]
longer
so it's coming out the side of the glass
it's like the flames
the gas and the flames are coming out
the side of the car whoops
colin you've got a leak never mind you
need to be a plumber that's
uncomfortable
yeah it is see some of that it follows
the outside
it's like there's like a beefier part
here in the middle
and then the flames come around the
outside and then clap together and go
back down again
it's amazing how much can go on yeah a
fraction of a second
and it's do it yeah because it is doing
that in milliseconds isn't it yeah
blowing out sucking you wouldn't think
it could and that's just all on its own
right so we've slow mode it we have a
better idea of what's going on inside i
think we just get it
glowing red hot now yeah so just leave
it going for yeah just keep it going
just let it glow
maybe then the glass may break oh
because i am
shocked that it has not broken will the
steel melt i mean what
i don't need your melt i've never got a
stainless one to melt
what is the melting point of stainless
steel i think it's 1200 degrees
that is hot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come back
yes you can't get anywhere near it it's
singing the table i don't know my hands
are quite cold actually
i actually get pretty quiet that was red
is in there
it's it's actually changed the color of
the glass as well oh yeah it's gone all
green
oh man this is lush as a radio they
probably wouldn't want to touch that
oh lovely nice nice on an english winter
right yeah
that was some lovely looking footage big
thanks to colin first for letting us
come and film his pulse jet that's right
it was class colin is secretly my
favorite british youtuber
um so make sure you give him a big wet
subscribe subscribe to us as well if you
want
and we will see you in the next episode
of the slow-mo guys
how long did it take you to get home if
you took this like is your method of
propulsion are you talking home to texas
yeah yeah long time just sitting on the
ocean
good luck with that that was pretty
close i almost got singed how am i how
my hair's looking
oh
can you see like the turned up edges
yeah you've got a little bit of ginger
at the end of them
no i'm proud of these bad boys as well
you're proud of it you called your
eyelashes bad boys yeah they're so long
and lovely